The Headless Horseman rides tonight
through stark and starless skies
Shattering the silence with his otherworldly cries
He races through the darkness of his alabaster steed
the Headless Horseman rides tonight
Wherever the fates would lead
After the video on the Dullahan it seemed like many of you were interested in the origins of theHeadless Horseman
So today we'll take a look at some Headless Horseman stories from a few different countries
the first headless horseman story is one
that some of you might be quite familiar with
because it's a story that was
popularised by Washington Irving
In American folklore the Headless Horseman was originally known as the headless Hessian of the Hollow
His story begins in New York during the Battle of White Plains
just one of the many battles that
took place in America's fight for independence from the British
The horseman was a hessian trooper who took part in the battle
Hessian troopers for those of you who don't know were German soldiers who fought for the British
During the battle this particular hessian trooper was unlucky enough to be decapitated by a cannonball
His body would be carried away by his comrades but his head which had been shattered into pieces was left scattered around the battlefield
His remains were then buried in the old Dutch Church of Sleepy Hollow
and legend has it that he would rise as a vengeful ghost in search for his lost head
the reason this tale was often
associated with Halloween and why the
Horseman's head is sometimes depicted as a pumpkin is because the battle took place on the 28th of October only a few days before the holiday
the idea of the horsemen being
decapitated in battle is quite common
and it's one that we see in Scottish
Welsh and English folklore
In both English and Welsh folklore we have the 14th century or Arthurian poem Sir Gawain and the Green Knight
This story centres around one of the Knights of Arthur's round table who is challenged to a duel
by a mysterious Green Knight
but this in itself isn't really a duel as the Green Knight tells Gawain that he will allow
him to strike him once and then he will
return the same blow a year and a day later
Gawain accepts this challenge
and with one swing of his axe he manages
to decapitate the Green Knights but the
knight then simply picks up his head
reminds Gawain that he will return in a
year's time and goes on his way
When he eventually finds this mysterious Green Knight Gawain accepts his fate and in an
attempt to keep his honour he leans over
expect in the night to return the blow and strike him down
after several fake swings of his axe
and a brief exchange the Green Knight
explains to Gawain that he was actually
transformed by Arthur's sister Morgan la
Fey
this whole challenge and adventure was merely just a ploy to expose Arthur's knights and to show how chivalrous they really were
this story is quite long and there certainly are some things that I haven't mentioned
and that's because I'd like to cover
this in some more detail when I start
discussing these stories of King Arthur and arthurian lore itself
In Scotland the Headless Horseman was said to be a man named Ewan who fought for leadership of his clan
During a battle on the Isle of Mul both Ewan and his horse were decapitated and thus ending his hopes of ever being the chieftain
But the legends state that both man and horse still haunt the surrounding area even to this day
for our next legend we travel all the
way to northern India and the state of Rajasthan
This variation of the Headless Horseman was seen as a more heroic figure who was said to protect the innocent
these stories usually describe the horsemen as being born from a violent death
the most common story is about a prince
who was decapitated while defending his village from the thieves
Even once he was beheaded he continued to defend his people
This version of the horseman
was said to fight without a horse so he isn't really a horseman
but there is a story of a guard who died defending his prince in battle
Despite his death the guard continued to defend his prince and he enters the battle mounted on a horse without a head
Our last two stories take us to Germany where the Brothers Grimm wrote several stories about the Headless Horseman
The first story set in the town of Dresden and follows a woman who is gathering acorns in a part of the forest named the lost waters
the woman then hears the sound of a hunting horn and when she turns she sees a man riding a grey horse
which isn't too out of the ordinary so she continues collecting acorns and goes home
when she later returned to the forest she heard a voice from behind her
and when she turned she
saw the same man dressed in grey
this time carrying his head under his arm he
then tells a woman that his name is Hans
he then tells a woman that his name is Hans Jagenteufel and during his life he never once did he do warnings of his father
to be courteous and merciful to all those
below him
he often drank excessively and indulged himself far too much without a care for those around him
and so now in death he was cursed to roam the earth as
an evil spirit
the second story is of the wild Huntsman of Brunswick the Huntsman went by the name of Hackelberg
and on his death he begged God to allow
him to stay on earth and in exchange he would sacrifice his place in heaven
his request would be granted but he would remain on earth as a headless horseman
Hackelberg was said to blow his horn to warn other hunters that the next day would not be safe for hunting
in some stories he would even seek out and punish those who had wronged to others
accompanied by his pack of black hounds
with tongues of fire
these two stories certainly tie into the themes of God and morality that we see all throughout the Grimm stories
Most of these tales despite where they're from seem to share a similar origin
horseman is nearly always driven by revenge often slain in a battlefield of some kind
then of course you have stories where the horseman is more of a protector figure and even a vigilante
I'm sure many of you would have heard similar stories so feel free to share those with me in the comments below
as always I've been your host
Mythology and fiction explained